Citizen Kane no metropolis no Return of
the King no this week marks the 20th
anniversary of the release of chicken
run in the UK in the u.s. saw it a week
earlier but the film was made here in
the UK so I'm gonna count this as the
20th anniversary of I tweeted out that
the anniversary of the greatest film
ever made was coming up and perhaps I
should make a video about it and people
seemed really keen on that idea so here
we are my job in this video is to
convince you that chicken run an
animated movie by aardman Studios about
chickens trying to escape a chicken farm
is in fact the greatest movie ever made
a position that I do kind of hold I want
to talk about the film itself how the
film was made and what the purpose of
art is in general then the end of the
video I'm going to bring that all
together to make my argument first the
film if you talk to anyone who has seen
chicken none they will almost always
come back to you with a quote
[Music]
chickens go in pies come out what kind
of mine my favorite chicky great lummox
the film is chock-full of great jokes
that's actually a joke in itself if you
for some reason haven't seen chicken run
yet then it is a comedy an animated film
set in Tweedy's chicken farm a stand-in
for Ag Nazi prisoner of war camp where
the imprisoned chickens are desperate to
escape one day an American rooster
called rocky falls from the sky and
offers them a chance to fly out of the
farm the Rocky is not who he seems the
film is wildly successful as a comedy
the writing is great that jokes are
funny the exemplifies a certain kind of
dry British humor that's very different
from the typical kind of humour you find
in most American animated films but the
humor is only one part of the film the
defining characteristic of a comedy may
be and so by which measure it is already
great but what else does the film have
to offer the story it's engaging it
reflects some deep-seated ideas in
British cultural identity like wartime
spirit and the plucky underdog community
of rising up to defeat tyranny
cinematography the film is beautiful its
use of claymation which we'll come back
to in just a minute is masterful and
beyond that the matte paintings used are
beautiful as well it's conventional
cinematography the lighting and the use
of the camera drive the story forward
effectively but even better than how the
movie looks is how the movie sounds for
my money chicken run has the most
underrated film score of all time John
Powell and Harry gregson-williams did
not need to go as hard as they did on
this score what's particularly amazing
to me are all the little references in
the music obviously it's very heavily
inspired by world war ii era films like
The Great Escape
Mack you'll handle the engineering bad
manufacturing but there are lots of
little references to much like the film
has lots of visual references to other
films the score has lots of little
references and interweaves itself with
the rest of the Western musical
tradition
[Music]
and somehow it despite a film coming out
before Pirates of the Caribbean there's
this section
[Music]
what and of course kazoos the musical
school has a part literally written for
kazoos and that's just silly
and brilliant
[Music]
next how the film was made chicken run
was made by aardman an indie studio
based in Bristol in the UK which is also
my hometown does that is my opinion of
the film yes
admin have previously won great acclaim
for their fantastic Wallace & Gromit
shorts a grand day out the wrong
trousers and a close shave if you
haven't seen them yet what are you doing
it was when Nick Park and Peter Lord the
cofounders of aardman were at the
Sundance Film Festival showing a close
shave which instantly went on to win an
Oscar when they got a call from
DreamWorks Steven Spielberg had arranged
for private jets to fly them to LA to
talk future projects and then in Nick
parks own words by coincidence they
arranged for the meeting to take place
and a famous chicken restaurant at that
point all we had were a few thoughts
scribbled on a scrap of paper but the
idea of chickens plotting their grand
escape went down really well I remember
Steven saying that the Great Escape was
his favorite film and he had 300
chickens on his farm I like to imagine
that Spielberg didn't realize they they
wanted to make an animated film so the
project was this combination of this
tiny British indie studio in this
billion-dollar American distributor once
you add in some funding from the French
studio path a the project was go and
from the very beginning it was
multinational it relied on cooperation
between people who lived thousands of
miles apart and lived very different
lives but the actual film making took
place in Bristol and the film was made
of course with claymation when I was in
secondary school I co-founded an
animation Club every Thursday lunchtime
under the eye of mr. nevan's we would
make simple animations some of them were
done on the computer some of them were
using different bits of paper shot from
above the most time-consuming ones of
all with one shot using tiny clay models
claymation involves making high quality
poseable models with interchangeable
parts that apposed photographed moved
ever so slightly and then photographed
again repeat this process 24 times and
you'll have captured one second of film
the complexity of the production on
chicken run was such that the animators
and there were lots of them would
average 2 or 3 seconds of finished film
a
if they reached a minute in a week they
would crack out the champagne I mean
just look at this scene and imagine how
many tiny precisely calculated movements
are required between each and every
frame the work required is astonishing
and all this is on top of your normal
filmmaking process lighting choosing
lenses directing getting good
performances from your performers
claymation is quite possibly the most
time-consuming the most intensive method
of making movies and the result is
unique it's something that's undeniably
art but what is the point of doing all
this what is the point of art now I'm
just a mere scientist turned
professional nerd so take my a personal
opinion on this with a pinch of salt to
create art in my opinion is to be human
it externalizes an internal feeling or
concept for others to experience for
example when Palestrina wrote the Miss
epatha March le 450 years ago he created
a Link to the Past that whenever it's
performed allows others in the audience
to experience the feelings that he
himself felt when he composed it and
further connects all those who have
heard it throughout history it brings us
together with a shared experience
separated through time and art is a
fundamental currency it's important that
we create it because humans need to
consume art for our souls just as we
need to consume food for our bodies
art is simultaneously a mirror for the
artist and their cultural context and
also a window for future generations to
learn and draw nourishment from so what
does this all have to do a chicken man
like all films it is art and so carries
with it an idea the idea that chicken
run encapsulates is multi-layered in
part it is a triumphant tale a human
tale of adversity over the odds
succeeding despite every circumstance
being against you on another level it is
both multinational and distinctly local
with dry British humor and self
deprecation made possible by an
interconnected world reflecting the
culture that produced it as all art does
proudly wearing
on its sleeve while weaving into the
broader human experience but most
fundamentally it is absurd the film
draws a direct comparison between
chickens trying to escape a chicken farm
and prisoners of war trying to escape
the most brutal barbaric regime in
recent history and the fact that we as
humans decide to reflect absurdity in
our art is the most human thing of all
because of life is absurd it is futile
we all die and the heat death of the
universe is inevitable as entropy claims
us all and every memory we ever imprint
in the sand and in the face and all of
that we make a film about chickens not
wanting to be in pies we laugh in the
face of inevitability and say we're
gonna do our own thing anyway with the
precious time available to us in the
most time-consuming artistically
challenging medium of all we make a film
that elicits our deepest emotions and
fears and base it on an absurdity
chicken run represents the best of
humanity the highs to which we saw the
strength of our spirit and the depths of
our depravity chicken run is humanity
manifest and that is the ultimate
function of art and that is why it is
the greatest film ever made your food
for my soul very least thank you for
making it to the end of the video for
some reason I hope you enjoyed it if you
did pop it or like if you wanna see more
videos like this then subscribe I don't
normally make videos like this but if
this does particularly well then I will
make more videos like this so you should
subscribe and let me know in the
comments what you thought that's a video
I just made isn't it thanks for watching
I'll see you in the next one